then where I'm doing my I do a podcast
with Ari and Tripoli called punch-drunk
so I'm doing punch-drunk the next
[ __ ] day I go oh by the way i texted
Joey Diaz about doing my show and they
both got oh [ __ ] doggie shouldn't have
[ __ ] I go yeah nobody told me this I
didn't know you had this rule you don't
text me [ __ ] how's punch-drunk doing
great man Don then do it you guys been
doing it for a while every Tuesday noon
attune it's just sports I mean it's
probably twenty percent support people
say they [ __ ] around the Rousey on there
yeah we have a lot of people Ahlers GSP
Georges st. Pierre calls in the Diaz
brothers a dice clay you know different
people call in and they have you know
stories to tell but you know really when
we started it you know cuz all three of
us are doing podcasts and different
things and we've always been in the
store parking lot talking you know kind
of yeah you see the game last night it
was fun to [ __ ] the lakers or whatever
and you would have a our conversation it
would start with sports but then it's
just like you know what's up with you in
this chick I saw last night it just gets
into regular [ __ ] so we were like to be
a funny idea for a show of three comic
front you know all three of has been
friends for 16 years of like let's try
to talk a little sports but I'm sure
it's gonna get into [ __ ] you know
just regular life [ __ ] so you know we
probably thirty percent sports so
something like that wait meetings in LA
yep not a la not a Hollywood but in that
way I hear the Hollywood meeting is a
[ __ ] up oh there's some good ones good
ones yeah there's some good ones uh but
yeah yeah just all you know west side
thanks Ali sure how do they make money
cuz i was i went to d agostino birthday
on magnolia and there's a an a a meeting
right next door in like a sign it's a
place that does meetings all day mm-hmm
and you take donations you pass a basket
wow this place's two-wheelers all the
time they do yeah usually a place will
let you sort of it was in a church but
some of them okay yeah there's like two
thousand meetings a week in LA so I
Facebook somebody maybe four years ago
yeah this is a true story Facebook them
they were very close to me and one day
something came up missing and right
they pointed their finger at me I was
very hurt about it Oh 20 30 years past I
always thought about them you know I
contacted the sister she hit me back but
I contacted the one system and the one
brother they didn't hit me back when I
went to Miami cool it the two girls
showed up but the cousin didn't show I
was very tight with the cousin the other
day the [ __ ] phone rings so Miami
call I'm busy doing the podcast when i
get home i forget to call an i check
facebook and it was him Hawaii you know
I mean we grew up together yeah very
[ __ ] painful that he is family
accused me it was [ __ ] bad but what
was it got stolen if you don't I'm
asking there was a watch or a [ __ ]
ring or rains I don't remember what your
worries I get all house I get over there
they're like you're not allowed here no
more there's what happened get your
stuff you gotta go this is a fair you
know I hadn't known these people all my
life he knew my parents is very sad and
trust me I was no angel at the time this
was this went on because i was involved
in other things that sometimes karma
smacking reputation for supper
associations I was really heard it made
me go on a tan and my uncle it made me
want a drug tabs do I was living in a
spaceship at a park you know those parks
that have the kids spaceship he was
living under the spaceship get out of
here I was bad people I've had my
bachelor addiction sure and I love
talking about it because talking about
it helps other people they don't feel
that shitty about their line yeah I was
there you know I was smoking there was a
time I figured out you know what I'm
spending too much money on blow on the
way home at night on in between sunset
and hollywood Selma yes by the way the
[ __ ] people just like superheroes
yeah yeah oral orange and some of the
uses so crack their punch I mean you
drive there one there be ten black dudes
out there running to your car over I
didn't know one that I was looking for
blonde I pulled up and the guy goes you
looking we made eye contact give me a
chunk I went home I tried to start it I
went I got dizzy and [ __ ] and I told my
friends I said was that wasn't blown
that was cracked stupid so I said that
wasn't a bad chunk for twenty bucks I
spoke to her head at the house I got
[ __ ] up so for six seven eight weeks I
smell practice that's a hard one is a
charity I go home and tell Terry go to
bed she wake up and go what is that
smell like what's the weed she goes I
smell you weed for years I never snot
weed that bad she little so I would snow
get out of a coke can that's how crazy I
was so I smoked weed out of a cocaine no
crack oh no just saying I the cocoa my
mother I would tell her was we but I put
crack in there I like smokin I mean I've
done some dirty you my nails used to be
[ __ ] filthy in those days from
touching the crack in a lot of ways
you're lucky to be alive yes but this is
what it gets to this is the worst
because i always felt bad about this I
always felt bad the first day I read
about whitney houston's daughter the
first day I read about that I know
exactly what happened I know exactly
what happened I know it didn't take a
genius you know and and they whatever
and they kept talking I for the first
month I knew she was dead it was just a
matter its sure but it gave me time a
lot of time to think you know and I
don't after my mother died for like two
or three years I could not jump off a
building as bad as I wanted to or I can
not shoot myself as bad as I wanted to
so subconsciously the reason why I could
smoke as much as i do because at the age
of 15 and 16 I did everything an
enormous amount yeah I wanted to die but
I have the balls to do it so I'll eat
those quaaludes you know those [ __ ]
quaaludes are strong especially bad
you're safe then [ __ ] strong dog you
drink a bottle of vodka with a quaver
you playing in a certain [ __ ]
neighborhood that's like each other a
lot of people and I mean you look at my
eyes and there's veins of the pop those
are from nights with quaaludes you could
feel the heat in your head and [ __ ]
listen man and at that time I was just
had a pain that was intolerable mm-hmm
it was the pain of losing your mother
and wanting answers you know and not
just losing a mother but losing your
world because she was with Whitney was a
world but also in that world came a lot
of bad things I can on my
you know at the age of [ __ ] the seven
I knew my mom did blow it was very
embarrassing and I would go to play with
kids and there we go what's that thing
about cocaine I'll have to sit there and
not say a word what are you covering Lee
what do you got an anthem the end what
what do you got in the am pick in the
hand nothing why is your hand they're
all creepy-like you holding the [ __ ]
scorpion assumption that is what it look
like you really like a mobile a moment
closer spider the other way there you go
so I saw my mom due to drugs I saw you
know I never pinata at my birthday
parties and then second pinata shoot for
cocaine bindles in there for the adults
who really she would tell me get on the
floor if you see an aluminum foil pick
him up and bring him back to mommy I
mean I know my mom saw blood we had the
bar that was what those Cubans did at
the time sure so living with that I
never wanted to do blow but then I a
month before she died maybe two weeks
before she died I did [ __ ] blow and I
remember I had it for like two or three
months and I was like I'll never do this
i'll sell it I think I sold some of it
but I kept 11 afternoon less I'm taking
this out with me I know exactly what the
[ __ ] I was doing yeah because once you
see your hero do something you're gonna
do it ok you know you see your parents
can send you to aunt's house on the
Friday night you come back saturday
morning they're [ __ ] all over your
dad's like I'm not playing with you
today I'm on the couch son whatever
would you guys do less than how we drank
you see empty beer bottles you know then
when you turn thirteen you want to do it
you know people don't know that if your
heroes do something our parents are our
[ __ ] heroes so if you see your
parents drink you're gonna [ __ ] drink
oh you're gonna think it's okay to drink
sure you know I never wanted to be a
drinker but my parents do it it might be
okay you know I sure totally this poor
girl lost her world and yeah she had the
father but Bobby brenell is your fault
it's like having me as your [ __ ]
fault you know at that point for him he
was [ __ ] up he raised that girl [ __ ]
up that girl was raised on a [ __ ]
plane with a nanny given the money what
I wasn't when Whitney Houston Bobby
Brown did blow who took care that kid I
[ __ ] nanny and nothing below to that
getting two thousand a week and a couple
lines for taking care that [ __ ] kid
and she might sing or something who do
you think that I mean these people
started [ __ ] blow a lot these were
[ __ ] a real party big they were in
Miami what do you think that kid was so
your kid knows what's going on what do
you think that kid was gonna do what do
you think my mother thought I was gonna
grow up to do there was gonna be a
[ __ ] doctor I saw you do blow I found
blowing the [ __ ] basement I found
bales of weed in the basement what the
[ __ ] do you expect me to do low in
piñatas I found blowing [ __ ] pinatas
the point being that she was my world my
mom I didn't have a dad you know she was
my world same thing they pulled the plug
I can't describe to you the pain I was
walking around and I didn't know it till
this girl died yesterday when she died I
broke down yesterday because I know it
shout it just brought it back I remember
what she would I remember you know I
used to boys to get [ __ ] up and go to
the house where I found my mother and
I'd sit on the stairs hoping hoping that
maybe this was all on the state yeah
maybe my mom open the door go get the
[ __ ] in here where the [ __ ] have you
been for a month you dumb [ __ ] yeah like
that's how delusional I got in the back
of my mind when you get that when you
bury somebody you see him in a casket
for five days but when somebody that big
in your life goes it's like a dream like
you like it's going you know eventually
I'm gonna wake up my mom's gonna make
mistaken eggs like she always oh yeah
the phone rings you're like oh that
that's my ma cheticamp it was I just
remembered this years ago I started
writing I would go at first like the
first two weeks three weeks after she
died after i moved him with the Bender's
the electricity was still on I think the
electricity stayed on till about January
and during the holidays I would go over
any afternoons after school and just sit
there hoping that she walked through
like a hit at night the mice had taken
over the house I would sit on that the
chair and just it was a silent house
mm-hmm I wouldn't put the TV on I just
stay here her maybe she was in the
basement cooking getting something this
is a misunderstanding is how delusional
i got sure so i know where that little
girl was but she was doing those drugs
man she doesn't want to live without her
mother I didn't want to live with I
didn't want to go without my mother man
hmm so I and I insight now I really
understand addiction that's why I wanted
to have you on the show you know people
would come to me and say and i would ask
about you I always asked about people
now he's drinking me that you know
whatever Tebow's gonna get it together
if I got it together these guys could
get it together more decent than I am I
wasn't no genius I took me [ __ ] 244
to realize so you're way ahead of the
curve no and you I can't when I meet
somebody not like I have a friend Jodie
who's a great girl and she just 42 is
she single you know you call her at
eleven tebow she's having yeah haven't
you could hear it mackerel a Hannah but
she's my friend I'm not that a judger
but in my mind I'm thinking Jesus Christ
when is this gonna end yeah when is she
gonna take this seriously because I
didn't want to be ray charles i didn't
want to get clean and sober 60 [ __ ]
one right you know off heroin a blow I
didn't want like I told Joe Rogan I
didn't want people pulling Joe roses on
I told you I told you he was a [ __ ]
junkie I didn't want to die in Houston I
didn't want my wife to find me on the
floor one morning she could never I
didn't want all these things but you
remember when a when a Mitch Hedberg
died absolutely um when he died you know
everybody that knew her knew his wife or
you know in any part of his life or
whatever when he died when you got when
anybody got that call nobody was like
what happened everyone was just like
where would they find him you know I
mean no one was like oh I got hit by a
car you got what I will you know plane
crash how did he die if I knew how he
died so no I'm gonna you know somebody
would call me like a man Mitch dad you'd
be like where you know I noticed that no
one ever said how everyone just said
where I was not didn't want to be that
guy I didn't want to be a guy that diet
48 and when people heard they're like
where they find him or you know
drinking and driving or whatever the
[ __ ] you mean it's like you know I get a
lot of it's just like give yourself a
[ __ ] chance man give us a [ __ ]
chance and it's like earlier when you're
saying it like you're stuck you know if
you're stuck all that really mean it
doesn't mean you're [ __ ] it means you
got to change something something has to
change if you're stuck you know it's the
only way you get unstuck you sit on you
write a plan you had a great plan tebow
I take my [ __ ] hat off to you man
that's the way I would do it but a lot
of people if I had was to do a line
again my life within three days later I
know for a fact I mean it's like the
bribes 52 drinks I'm having 20 no
there's no like I said at the beginning
his pockets like there's no sense in
having two drinks to me never was never
will be there's no sense where's our
friend where's your ex-girlfriend that
was cleaning so well I haven't I don't
know i'm not sure what she's up to
winter has anybody seen her oh I saw her
for a couple of weeks I'm talking about
the bigger yeah yeah I never saw her
again in a club I for years I saw out I
don't think she does a lot of clubs
stand up gigs I mean she'll do bar gigs
here and there I'll see him on facebook
or some [ __ ] but she not didn't end well
let's just say that our ending wasn't
didn't end well I haven't seen I think
about I thought that she had a lot going
on reuven I know she got a couple good
jobs or something the last couple months
yeah I know she really works the program
I'm Gil she really works the program so
I know should always teams like I said
man I wanted to have you on if you could
tell you story I'm glad I was odd to
your podcasting time and a lot of people
like you tbling a lot of people when I
go on the road people ask me buddy so I
know this is in your future you really
give this a chance and really go you
know what if I got a breakdown I'll
[ __ ] smoke a number with the sand and
i'll keep this under control and my
friends will watch me but uh like I said
I don't ever want to feel like I don't
blow in the last 10 years was such a
will I just did it because I might dig
that hard when I drove down the street
make the left turn you know my dick got
hard when that action I figures i missed
that [ __ ] criminality so this was my
replacement I'd miss jumping through
windows i miss [ __ ] scoping out tebow
soon as tebow [ __ ] leaves we call me
I'm gonna go breaking through his window
and take two pounds of coke phone I
missed action that cocaine gave me
action now that I think about it I
[ __ ] hate I would look at myself and
my pic my face and cry and yeah I can be
sick to my stomach you know that this
thing had such a [ __ ] grip on me and
it's also I think that's another thing
of addiction it's like when you're on it
you you don't see things for what they
are you know I'd be like a man
everybody's loving me and this is great
and then it's like you're like that
you're annoying the [ __ ] out of
everybody you know I do podcasts hammer
if you're like you wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up don't even know what the [ __ ]
you were talking about not letting other
people talk you're not even listening
it's like but that's not how I saw it in
my head you know them in so then when
you look back on hindsight you can like
my [ __ ] man I don't want to be that
[ __ ] guy my brother my heart goes out
to you I'm very proudly and I want you
to know I was always a dear friend he I
just didn't know where you were coming
from if you ever need anything will you
know you're the best and we give
something out after i get shot i'll give
you a ride to the train and will abandon
ship we how you feeling [ __ ] I'm
gonna smoke some more these vapors not
really do you always this party never
ends with plant flavor how you gonna act
you know how your [ __ ] you're doing
good though you look at me looking do a
little purple shirt time you got
sponsors you [ __ ] smacking
[ __ ] I want to redondo beach
have you been there for the for the
shrimp huh have you been to redondo
beach I got on my bicycle once a week
talk son yeah redondo beach I got time
to go to [ __ ] macondo
that time we don't meal in Chicago and
not get an Italian because it was down
the [ __ ] blocks from the house and
they don't have an attack to the walk I
went around the qualitative Talon beef
it looked like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the color of it would you eat
that Italian be by to [ __ ] Mexicans
would you do that no mr. beef was closed
by yeah I just didn't know I know that
is about all we missed the beef if I
gotta settle for anything mr. beaver
houses yeah house so I wasn't close to
them I was on [ __ ] downtown and it
looked it they made gyros at the same
place they made of beef and they made I
don't like french fries it was it was a
[ __ ] regular [ __ ] dump so I didn't
want pastrami once you have that many
combinations yeah to Spanish he's a
Chinese food yeah no no no there wasn't
really nothing good in there except
Mario's and then I went to rosemont tell
him what some rosemont who God's they
don't have a gas station they got a
foger the [ __ ] shower across from a
comedy club I wasn't doing 70 bucks the
two ounces of meat you know I felt with
a child you got to smoke 55 joints and
make it worth your while no [ __ ] it's
not as 70 bucks apiece yeah you got to
go in there hungry hungry [ __ ] and then
after you get your money's worth but
then you're [ __ ] you know after you
eat 20 pieces of garlic beef you like
this is great now you gotta sit there
for an hour and go I don't know if I
could drive home I love my guts I'm
gonna come out of my [ __ ] ears
because you know you're gonna drop a
[ __ ] shipment of money let me give
this readout first one to my man diese
dorchester for referring a one day as a
lion I hadn't heard that in the wall you
bad [ __ ] Abraham Baja or
whatever your [ __ ] name is Abraham
buy a diet you know I love you smile a
smiler Mike Jones jr. Kevin night
talking lair Cleo get ahold delete I got
two weeks off let's pick a day and do
this [ __ ] podcast James trolls and my
main man showed up to the show brought
me a book he brought gave me some cigars
I gotta give you a little stuffed animal
of the guys Bob love Lingus and his
beautiful father and they include the
shirts I love Bob lowliness and it's
funny friday night you start meeting
these people on the road mm-hmm
you communicate with them on facebook or
gmail and they send you a little gift
see you could tell where they're coming
from you love them the genuine it's
funny that friday night I was like I
didn't [ __ ] see Bob that's [ __ ]
weird I didn't talk to him on facebook i
didn't talk to him maybe he doesn't know
and Saturn I'm on stage and I looked
down in this bar but his dad right in
front of me I feel like [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] I didn't have anxiety that night
I just want straight up there what's up
with you [ __ ] licker and then Sean
tyranny sentences god Bruce Lee shirts
all that the Bruce Lee shirts thank your
brother some [ __ ] green tea to clean
up the system the adrenals you going to
a kettlebell class with me to my left oh
yeah we only go have a good time over
our vMac it's gonna be fun six people
already signed up for tomorrow but he's
got like an eight-pound weight to train
you with just to teach your form okay
and what you could do is you go to a
couple weeks just go to the kettlebell
class and then just stay for the sound
and you're done for the week and you'll
walk around so for two days [ __ ] long
work that's something different brother
that's true you're 27 year old man oh is
it glass for our but you do a lot of
stretching you do a lot of sit-ups just
like two hours jiu-jitsu two hours and
you do a lot of [ __ ] there so just get
used to the kettle bells and then go to
jiu-jitsu on Thursday this week and you
start going that twice a week once for
jiu jitsu 14 kettlebell and then one day
when you're ready to go you're slim jim
Magoo you go [ __ ] I'll do the
kettlebells I can't do both I'm now ty
won't walk on Wednesday and Thursday I
didn't walk on Wednesday and Thursday
after the kettlebells geez I didn't work
out on Friday it's really cool watching
the UFC now that I started to do too and
it was cool for me like i didn't
understand it like I still in class from
drilling that the mistake i'm making is
i'm going too fast yeah John bud said
you moved well on the floor he goes for
a little stocky little spending money
it's not you but it's not good because
won't you get good but then i was
watching the UFC and they're there for a
minute like 30 seconds just getting like
i like you don't have to do it right
away right nothing Morgan we're getting
work it but what you're doing is you're
putting pressure on your opponent so
that leg is on his leg that's what I
messing your leg is on his thigh and he
can't move his da he's lying you got 20
pounds on this
I so he's just grilling up that leg
you're playing like a hand thing and
everything you go for he's got it react
so one time he's gonna make a mistake
and actually you push and then you take
it from there where we doing the [ __ ]
you do to us in here sure that's right I
love you concert I ludie tapes coming up
you know that somebody know you I know
Sam is revamping the show and you guys
are doing it at a hotel in the Hollywood
that's the w yeah after w so that's
gonna happen pretty soon that's gonna be
rockin yeah that's gonna be awesome are
you doing it he called me and he doesn't
give me a date he goes on life here to
do it okay I've always you know I look
at you I think it's August nineteenth
I'm not sure could be somewhere in there
knocking young kids and I was an old guy
and now we're getting older but the most
important thing is we're still here yeah
and people have bounced back listen man
what's that dude that plays [ __ ]
Robert Downey jr. I got caught in a room
and venice right really I can Batman
suit jerking off nope that's how at the
end of his addiction he would buy that's
what I was doing he got pulled over in
his Porsche totally naked with a loaded
handgun and like a half a [ __ ] pound
of coke in the front seat of a
convertible Porsche they pulled him over
to look in the [ __ ] front seat it's
like a [ __ ] brick of coke a loaded
handgun and he's completely naked you
didn't race and now he's [ __ ] you
have no idea jobber super rich no
[ __ ] I Amanda you get your life
together you move on and you realize
that life has so much the [ __ ] law
firm man it really does like I couldn't
imagine going back now no I couldn't
imagine going back now I love my reefer
I don't want to get no problem at all I
couldn't even imagine having it on me
and my presence just or and it wasn't
bad was what I brought on myself that's
damning [ __ ] mind the [ __ ] i justwe
missed and this guy oh that guy oh just
when he says look if you were gonna have
a joint that like bullet is that
everybody has a vice week right
everybody's gotta do something everybody
goes home at the other night and dresses
up like a woman or stick to cube dipping
his nutsack or does something everybody
has to get up see us these [ __ ]
people who
politicians and I don't drink and I'm a
Christian then you find that they're
[ __ ] a black coat center yeah you
know that's the truth that's that
everybody has something it's calming
that something what's the easier when it
came to me I said you know what was it I
gotta do something I'm not just gonna
sit there and go to meetings and hug
somebody that won't work for me right I
gotta kill my evil switch which was the
blow what makes me miss jobs what makes
me yell at people did I am sheets what
makes me [ __ ] dude the [ __ ] I do
cocaine reef has never made me break
through a [ __ ] window wanna stay up
all night it's never done that to me
alcohol used to be my gateway sure and
because in those days even though like
it's so weird the tricks you play on
yourself i would say i'm not gonna go on
do blow tonight how does it go at four
do i have two drinks i would happen in
those days a drink southern comfort our
issues hmm i was nineteen twenty-seven
comfort or just get three of those and i
need blood three of those you need blow
and here i am in the sand and I knew
what trap I was walking into I'm not a
[ __ ] I knew by walking and escape get
in line to yourself you just lie to
yourself this is a weird thing addiction
man and got really good at lying to
myself like I would really believe this
[ __ ] that would come out of my mouth
even including like I'm cool man i got
this i'm not gonna drink today a little
[ __ ] like that and it's like [ __ ]
three o'clock and Anthony and I'm
shit-faced it's like three o'clock now
be drinking and [ __ ] you know these
dive bars and all these old dudes with
big noses and I'm you know 35 these guys
r hat twice my age just [ __ ] tying it
on I'm happy you got everything together
and I continued success thank you buddy
help from me please don't hesitate you
know I've been down that block I know
what it is to it took me like I'm gonna
be even six much being clean on blow
every day I walked on eggshells sir I'm
going to do that's a daily rind and I
wasn't waiting for my cat got hit but no
no I just knew them one
a snap but I never stopped yeah every
time I thought about it Sam prayer and
go you know I gotta think of this I
don't want to die I knew I would die I
just some people say use that term iya I
got be asked you I knew I was like so I
at night towards the end of the night
when I was coming down off the blow I
would get electric shocks on my spine my
spine was starting to hurt that's not
good yeah that's not [ __ ] good lead
you got anything to tell me nothing to
tell you about I was wondering like how
how you dealt with in those six months
like going somewhere we're used to do
coke or all right people don't go to him
I didn't go to the comedy store I got
all those things free just I was still
friends with the drug dealers I kept in
touch with him hello I kept them and
that gave me a lot of people just take
the numbers out in fact I talked to my
drug dealer tonight he's in that new
movie with Compton Straight Outta correa
yeah so he asked me if only I called him
on to congratulate him because my wife
wants to see it and he said if I wanted
to go to cast and crew with him on the
fourteenth I mandala Washington DC's so
uh that's I did Doug I made a promise I
made a promise I made an old-time
promise something that we break on a
daily basis that is the worst day first
time we broke a promise or told a lie we
went into this dark [ __ ] avenue in
your life I stop lying when I was about
21 yeah you exaggerated from time to
time but to just tell somebody to blame
lie about something I was there I shot
him that I had to stop doing and I was
doing it to get me somewhere lu lu t boy
how to check Tebow listen pleasingly
give me 10,000 just give me the balance
of bloat old friend yeah yeah yeah it's
a bold outline sure i was doing those
type of lives you know that's the first
one you have to stop you know and then
it's just tough it's just very tough and
eventually you get the steps and for
some people it takes 40 years so for
some people take 50 is some people never
get it I that some people never get it
and the whole thing is just being honest
with yourself what you can
do that night I walked into the strip
club when I was in the halfway house I
was a month away from getting married
mm-hmm I got no shame to tell people in
this bar I was a month away from getting
married you're a man a [ __ ] strip
club I'm at a strip club going to poke
out of some chicks [ __ ] I gave it a
whole bag of blow I fingered her [ __ ]
I sniffed it I got this girl you know I
did everything for this program I'll
never forget that going over 36 and
Boulder there's a part where you connect
them I twenty-five to thirty six of the
i-70 I don't remember and you're coming
over a hill in bloomfield to hit bold
and i saw those lights i still remember
splitting my brace on because i was
jerking off in the [ __ ] car all over
my car salesman suit i had already came
like four times at the strip club I mean
I didn't [ __ ] her but I did everything
else doing I [ __ ] all over me and Here I
am jerking that's how hot she was I was
smelling my hands jerking off in the car
how embarrassing is that yeah has a
[ __ ] 30 year old or whatever the [ __ ]
I wasn't gonna get married the girl was
married had a kid and Here I am blowing
1,500 bucks on it and a half ounce of
blow giving this poor girl whatever the
[ __ ] i gave it you know it was just a
pathetic I think of this [ __ ] now it's
[ __ ] pathetic their [ __ ]
pathetically that I was so weak but
that's what it did I'll never forget
getting out of prison tebow prison yeah
that's the ultimate slap in the face as
a man you have no idea tbell rehab
litsea not passing you your car getting
a flat you have no idea how humiliating
it is is a man to be in prison for a man
to kick your better tell you to get up
Deebo come on my pleasure when you can
eat and tell you when you could eat and
adjust your life and then I Ghana guys I
couldn't wait to get the package and my
father-in-law had a trailer so in those
days the halfway houses gave you
furloughs so I think I waited I think
six days I gotta love Tuesday yeah
that's saturday i got a furlough and he
had a trailer on the property and i said
i'll just sleep on the trailer
my god i will in that trailer with her
like a [ __ ] half ounce of blow and it
was the first time in a year or
something steve-o luckily didn't
overdose oh my go you're [ __ ]
knocking that back I'll never forget
that night got by four in the morning i
had done like half of it and the rest of
it i dumped in the toilet and i was
looking out the windows and the guys
dressed in white with those [ __ ]
suits like that ba guys on ropes coming
down the trees that's how strong my
paranoia was yeah and me trying to sweep
whatever was on the floor for coke and
lick it up I was licking dust dog hair
and dirt and [ __ ] anyway good luck
thank you buddy I love you love you to
death every room once you really really
a brother to all of us no man I tried
I've been down there and know when it
comes to that [ __ ] all i can say is
listen I don't care how you get clean I
don't care how long it takes but it's
such a beautiful life and I talk some
[ __ ] I talk about [ __ ] and stabbing
people I'm telling you this as a brother
that there's such a beautiful life
waiting for you and after or a year or
two you know what you might go back to
some of your bad habits and that's fine
but you have to control you can't drink
like I know I cannot put cocaine and
wheels I know I can't book like cocaine
in my nose I got a quaint 11 hold on to
free i'm gonna drop all these nights
that's okay that's not the horse that
killed me sure let me read some sponsors
let's get the [ __ ] out of here you go
buddy as usual you [ __ ] up you need
help with your addiction alpha brain
will focus you [ __ ] this will
bring you right back that's to overturn
that [ __ ] you understand because you
start thinking about what's important
and what's not important that's part of
[ __ ] addiction beaten addiction you
realize what's important and what's not
in point what's I got to do it on it I
got no [ __ ] idea here's what I do
though all right I went for [ __ ]
swimming today with the baby I'd elapsed
and I also went to [ __ ] jiu jitsu at
ten in the morning with John Evan and I
just fall get on top of me don't let me
[ __ ] up that was the whole class play
don't let me up and I'll tell you what I
did on the shroom tech and I breathe and
I must have rolled around for 40 minutes
I'm gonna be sore as [ __ ] tomorrow don't
get
wrong but the shroom tech got me there
all right whether it's the alpha brain
whether it's the [ __ ] hemp protein
and SI e or chocolate which tastes
[ __ ] delicious whether it's a shroom
tech I tell you what honor is on top of
their [ __ ] game go to honor
calm right now see the great selection
of nutrients and supplements they have
if you like something go to the box and
press in church and you get ten percent
off like a gentleman and if you have
another program called stay on it when
they just take your credit card and they
mail directly to your house and prefers
to a month and they give it another
additional ten percent off so you
getting twenty percent off right there
you got to ask yourself who's better
than you going on it right now and press
enter and enjoy the great products they
have to offer you you're sitting there
going Joey I can't stop smoking I got
the answer [ __ ] hey these things
right there BAM tremendous they last
longer they taste better taking a cigars
they got e-cigarettes from 24 to 16 282
no [ __ ] nicotine in there you can
work yourself backwards and you get us
ignoring you get all four of those in
the cigar five to fifty that's right 5
450 go to the box and press in Joey's
charity and get five [ __ ] cigars for
50 bucks that's how we run it over there
hit ecigs tastes better last longer and
a big [ __ ] shout out to my brother's
up there in Northern California and
they'll get life done bad [ __ ]
up there making wax gorilla biscuits
white chocolate that tastes like Mexican
[ __ ] what's that drink my charter
horchata 250 milligrams but it don't end
there they want the best vapor pens in
the [ __ ] market you understand me you
could smoke vegetables out of there you
can smoke wax when it comes to wax and
dabbing nobody knows more about that
[ __ ] Danell delight calm go to nail the
light calm well I got a present Joey
Diaz Joey Diaz di AZ [ __ ] and get
twenty percent off your first order with
the vapor pen the best baby put in the
market they guarantee it they stand
behind it you called AV calls you back
in two [ __ ] minutes and you got your
action back ok a big shout out to nail
the life a big shout out to hear these
things and a big shout out to honor calm
go on through these web pages right now
and supporters help us out [ __ ] suck and
don't forget my people over that iron
Dave Foley looking at a [ __ ] window
hahaha i love you [ __ ] don't
forget i'm in DC improv or his 13th or
something like that to the 15 I'm taking
my CD brand new stuff will keep writing
every day you know how we do it come on
down Baltimore DC wherever the [ __ ]
you're from that's where you're going
you understand me and that's it I want
to thank Jason tebow for coming on and
drop in some addiction knowledge and
opening up his life to you I want to
thank Lisa after sitting down like a
dunce all these is a [ __ ] hat over
there you smoking more vapor cocksuck he
look good thank you but everything on my
husband she's good she's good she's
finishing up her work for the summer
it's uh what you guys doing this weekend
what do you think she's going to vegas
for the breakers wouldn't with her
college friends oh geez i have talking
there on the on the Security Division
girls are boys all girls so thank I
didn't go I got invited but we gonna go
like a half a [ __ ] and what I like beat
up and robbed camera first orange yeah
you ain't that type of mother [ __ ]
you're the real deal jack you're
slinging jus dick and giving out [ __ ]
Hanukkah cards again then I'm gonna be
in Toronto the same weekend you're in DC
doing a podcast look at you all right
then I go up there for you all right
tebow we got a date coming up uh when he
says come out tomorrow yeah okay I'll be
the icehouses friday actually do another
watch yeah that's what show this
partisan see i'll be down they'll be
great night for death squad how people
minding my own [ __ ] business i love
you guys knew you see you wednesday
night at the ice house is sold out it no
way sold out already and uh we'll see
you back thursday afternoon at three
o'clock my brothers have a great [ __ ]
night thank you for this to have a great
day tomorrow thank you for listening i
love you [ __ ]